once upon a time in a faraway land
they live a beautiful girl who dreamed
of finding her prince alas real life is
no fairy tale is white Disney princes
saw mrs. hawk would make terrible
boyfriends
my dad threw this party so I can meet a
girl who is especially independent hot
and rich like us so you married me think
I left my straightener heart
[Music]
Hey
[Music]
what are you doing oh thank god that's
your day why would you try to kiss me
hold on don't treat the subject who
these seven guys texting you
there's my rights
[Music]
so now that we live together we need to
establish a few ground rules actually
I'm hungry you are not allowed to step
foot into that side of the house
especially my room ever it is forbidden
okay does that include bath also I'm
gonna need to know where you are and
what you're doing at all times because
sometimes I get lonely do this and I'll
release your father from my basement
you can net my dad nail dad what are you
talking to you
[Music]
[Music]
we miss have you seen my girlfriend me
oh yeah you look familiar but wait I
follow you on twitter right you don't
remember the crazy lady you stabbed with
a boat I mean I think I know what the
love of my life looks like even the dog
knows it's me get my dog badge right now
where'd you go
[Music]
sorry babe do you spot me again
well my parents just cut me off no you
need to get a job I got a job my music
you woke up like that you woke up like
that no have fun making love to your
MIDI guitar it's a ukulele I can at
least borrow your car to get home take
the bus you're so fancy wait your name
is not ollie
Savino Aladdin yeah that's me a
compulsive liar someone who plunders why
are you singing I told you what you
wanted to hear to get inside your cave
of water who's Mickey for what now
convention is lepton was one that I kept
in the way I have a tostone D seat who
are you people
the car that we brought in there's one
that I'd stolen but who needs a ride
on the street your homeland that money
swear follows us everywhere is my one
and only
and
so yeah I've had the absolute worst luck
with dating wailing oh this is a little
awkward I kind of thought you were dude
excuse me it's just from certain angles
and I mean your hair is pulled back in
these photos yeah sorry I guess I made a
man out of you I have been looking
everywhere for you you know what I'm
done with Disney Princess being single
never bothered me anyway and she lived
happily ever after why this always keep
happening to me
hey are you doing ladies love it when
you kidnapped their fathers I'm gonna
build her a library you know what I mean
and by that I mean I'm going to actually
build a library seriously who are you
talking to talking to me eh
[Music]